Heidegger thought that Western
philosophy have gone wrong basically
since the time of socrates,
which was quite a long time and he said
that we were,
we became interested in what the world
was made of and how we knew things and
what we should have been interested in
stead was the nature and quality of
being and what he meant by being isn't
the objective world.
What he meant by being was the manner in
which you have experience and so there
were elements of being that aren't
objective elements and so I would say
pain is a phenomenological reality,
right?
It's not something you can.
You can index it objectively,
but the index is not the phenomena and
you know,
is your pain real.
See this as this is a question for
people who think there's no such thing
as meaning.
Like you try to argue yourself out of
pain and see how far you get.
You might think,
well,
that's not the sort of meaning I meant.
It's like,
you know,
a negative meaning is a place to start,
right?
Because if something's negative and it's
real,
it does imply that there's something
positive that's real.
It might be harder to get ahold of,
at least it's not pain,
but pain descartes,
and I'll close with this.
You guys can have a great day.
Cart implemented a method he called
radical doubt when he went on his
philosophical journey and what descartes
looked for was one thing he couldn't
doubt because he was probably clinically
depressed and he was just doubting
everything.
It's like,
well,
why?
How do I know the world isn't just been
Mirage made by an evil demon to,
you know,
to,
uh,
to obfuscate reality from me.
While his conclusion was the one thing
that he could not dispute was that he
could,
he was an could think.
Now,
I don't think they cart really meant
what we meant by think.
I think he meant more what we would mean
by experience because thought has become
a much more narrowly defined,
you know,
term since the time of descartes.
So I don't think he meant,
I think therefore I am.
I think he meant something like I
experienced.
I have experienced therefore yama.
Regardless of that martyr.
People think about it as thought
heidegger was different.
Heidegger basically said the one thing
you can dispute is that that experience
is your experience.
It exists.
You can't.
It's almost by definition,
right?
It's like the definition of exist and
then he was interested in what the
fundamental elements of existence I've
existed.
This work and they're not outcomes like
you know,
like the fundamental elements of the
object of world.
There are more things like pain and for
me that was the thing that stopped me
from Delhi.
It's like a candidate.
The existence of pain,
it seems real and I might say it seems
more real than anything else.
Now you might say you don't believe
that,
but I would say,
I don't care what you think you believe,
I'll watch you when you're in pain and
every single one of your actions will
indicate that you believed in it.
And not only that,
that you can't not believe in it.
Right?
It's there and it's there so much that,
well,
that's a meaning and so that it's in
that way that heidegger,
at least in part thought of existence as
or experience as composed of meetings.
And so part of the reason that this
course is called maps of meaning is
because one of the things we're going to
look at is the structure of meaning,
and we're going to start with negative
meaning because from my perspective,
it's,
look,
you can doubt whether or not good
exists,
but once I'm done telling you about the
things I know about human history,
there won't be a single person in this
room who thinks that evil doesn't exist
and you might think that's a bloody
horrible thing to learn,
but it's not.
It's unbelievably useful because once
you can establish something that you
cannot deny,
then you can move from that.
And I think you can hypothesize that if
you're capable of detecting radical
evil,
I'll tell you about unit seven,
31 at some point,
or you can look them up yourself.
I wouldn't recommend it.
By the way,
once you can identify radical evil and
you think,
well,
that's.
That's just beyond a doubt,
that's reprehensible.
There's no justification for that
whatsoever,
no matter what.
Whenever,
while then you've got something to stand
on and you can start thinking,
well,
what's the absolute opposite of that?
Then,
you know,
it might be,
how is it that you could conduct
yourself so that in your sphere of
influence,
the probability like that anything like
that would ever happen is reduced to the
absolute maximum.
Well,
that's a reasonable moral question.
And,
and,
and I,
I don't think it's something that you
can dispense with,
with like a casual nihilism.
I don't think a nihilist can dispense
with it because he even nihilists
suffer.
Thank God for that.
You know,
it's their only is their only source of
potential salvation.
Sometimes they notice it,
oh,
I'm suffering about all this nihilism.
Maybe that indicates that there's
something flawed in it.
It's always possible.